this next song we like to dedicate to
the victims and the families this
tragedy in Paris a moment of reflection
of the scorpions concert in Paris the
band performed their hit songs send me
an angel in memory of the victims of the
attacks
me
Oh
the entities in defense image a stagnant
on trot Simic the fans always sing the
chorus with us but we could still tell
that tonight had a different dimension
with their thoughts and emotions
everyone tried to incorporate the
terrible moments of 11 days ago and
establish an emotional connection if I'd
been no get sustained is Emma Watson
arla security was intense at the first
major concert in Paris since the
November 13th attacks when most of the
victims were killed at a rock concert
the Scorpions initially considered
canceling their show then visualize been
stars our neighbors if we as a band had
decided we won't perform what a bad sign
we've always stuck together as a gang of
five friends travel the world make music
and build bridges pudding born and right
now we're important as bridge builders
inside when the tragedy happened it was
clear we'd stick together as a band and
with our French friends and fans oil
defense the scorpions and France have
long had a special relationship the band
has a loyal following here that's also
evident in the documentary scorpions
forever and a day co-produced by
Deutsche Welle it's now being released
in French cinemas in 1984 the band
performed in Betsy one of the country's
largest venues shortly after its opening
their songs still loving you is the most
successful single of all time in France
and one of the emotional highlights of
the evening
it's a sign of European solidarity the
Scorpions love front it don't know if it
buried beneath we wanted to come and
talk the risk security was good the
terrorists won't win no subway will go
on and won't be afraid
the fans join together in solidarity
again when the crowd began singing an
impromptu version of the French national
anthem
Oh Natalie sure Bunnel of course you
know some young people there held up
banners that said but a club and they
made that direct connection and and it's
horrible to think that so many young
people who just wanted to have a good
time lost their lives of the concert
only a few days ago so fill your
momentum on slim becomes and the
ironwood off Sam Bowden
band's biggest hit wind of change was
also in the lineup much of the audience
of nearly 20,000 sang along in the
refrain
then do a head spin when you go out as a
band you're not afraid you have your own
aura
getn Norman this was just about humanity
nothing else humanity is the only thing
that counts in Sea Girt but see it
rock for freedom for the band now
marking its 50th anniversary it's a
concert that Bay and their fans will
always remember
I